the situation in the northeast has
become critical the army called in as
thousands enter a second week with no
power
soldiers now doing what they can to
reassure communities feeling completely
cut off
now i'm gonna stay now this is me now
i can't afford to go anywhere else
it comes on once
then it goes off
so i try and get everything done like my
water you know and everything but it's
just
not good and it's not good for my mental
health either
some residents here in northumberland
are opting to stay put or simply can't
afford to go anywhere else
with sleet and near freezing
temperatures forecast in the next 24
hours
concern is mounting
we've got to check on them daily to make
sure their welfare is okay and that has
proved life-saving in some instances
this week
reaching rural communities to check on
people's safety has become paramount the
army deploying nearly 300 troops to go
door-to-door
very much continuing to understand the
situation up here
and very much providing reassurance to
the locals in their towns and villages
which are still still suffering um and
then sign posting uh local specialist
agencies be they uh energy suppliers etc
uh to where problems still exist and
where they need to be dealt with
it's more than a week since storm irwin
battered parts of scotland the northeast
and cumbria regulator of gem has
launched an urgent review into the
response by energy companies to the
storm a northern power grid has issued
an apology
but many are angry at what they deem has
been a slow response to this crisis
there is a sense that we feel a bit
forgotten up here and if i could play
the grumpy northerner just for a moment
i do wonder if this is happening in the
southeast if you're taking the best part
of the week for the government to do
something
energy companies are working around the
clock to restore power
but that may still be days away thank
with distress growing as temperatures
drop